we are all incredibly fortunate tonight  because I've lost my voice it's too late  for any of the one-line Nifty's anyhow  so I'll get right to the meat and  potatoes the five leading ladies  nominated for the Best Performance by an  actress are Ellen Burstyn for Alice  doesn't live here anymore  Diahann Carroll for Claudine Faye  Dunaway for Chinatown valerie perrine  for Lenny Jenna Rowland's for a woman  under the influence  and the winner is Ellen Burstyn Alex  score city director about  but except for Olympus  thank you um Ellen is in a play tonight  in New York she can't be here she asked  me to thank everyone concerned with the  voting the Academy will vote for also  the entire cast and crew of Alice and  also especially John Kelly and Robert  Getchell and she also asked me to thank  myself thank you